vous êtes favorable à une commission
d'enquête sur Sainte Soline on voit bien
les députés Renaissance qui le veulent
une commission d'enquête qui portera je
le cite sur les récentes manifestations
illicites violentes une commission
d'enquête appréciée la présidente du
groupe Aurore berger qui est un moyen de
réaffirmer notre soutien à ceux qui nous
protègent là où certains veulent au
contraire les mettre en accusation votre
réaction Thomas dessus moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ouvre une commission
dans la même le même cadre de la
commission qui enquêtait sur le le
fiasco du Stade de France et qu'on
additionne tout le monde qu'on nous
disions comme on a additionné l'UEFA les
supporters la RATP le préfet le ministre
il faut qu'on aille au-delà de
simplement l'audition du ministre qui
peut répéter ces mensonges donc il faut
oui auditionner la LDH y compris les
élus sur place si vous voulez les
journalistes qui étaient sur place il
faut qu'on fasse une mission large pour
bien qu'on comprenne ce qui s'est passé
il y a qu'un jour au niveau du groupe
c'est là on veut le pousser pour que ça
pour que la commission des lois se
saisisse de ce sujet est-ce que vous
[Musique]
avec la plus grande objectivité on
écoute tout le monde dans cette maison
tout au moins bon donc voilà moi je suis
favorable à ça mais je pense qu'il
faudrait aller plus loin parce que le
problème qui s'est posé à ça ne solide
et c'est posé avant on va se poser dans
d'autres secteurs et donc faut éclairer
tout ça et la question que j'ai posé au
ministre ce matin est-ce que vous
disposez de tous les outils juridiques
et après des questions de
constitutionnalité qui se pose également
[Musique]